I stand here before you not as a prophet
as a humble servant it was one of those
things that you knew was inevitable 95
years old terribly ill fighting for his
life
for the past few years yet still nothing
could prepare you for that feeling of
sadness emptiness that came with the
passing of Nelson Mandela one of the
greatest leaders of our time growing up
in South Africa I was seven eight years
old and watching TV keenly with my
family when Nelson Mandela was released
from Victor first air prison on that
sunny day in 1990 regal and dignified
holding his wife Winnie's hand from
humble beginnings in the Eastern Cape he
became a fighter a rebel and a lawyer
who refused to submit to South Africa's
apartheid regime a man who lost 27 years
of his life to incarceration on Robben
Island the apartheid media used to call
him the black Pimpernel Margaret
Thatcher called him a terrorist he was a
symbol of everything good that could
emerge out of the darkness of apartheid
a racist and brutal system he gave us a
renewed hope that we could live in a new
country reborn and he fulfilled that
hope four years later when he was
elected president he showed us South
Africans how to choose forgiveness I
noted saying of his was that resentment
is like drinking poison and hoping it
will kill your enemies Mandela outlasted
outplayed and outclassed them all and
then he won them over for him they were
far too many pressing issues at hand
than to try to settle old scores he
could have stayed on as president for as
long as he wanted to that's how much we
loved him
but he chose one term and then stepped
down south africa under Mandela and
after Mandela was and is by no means
perfect a teenage country still trying
to find its way in the world
an imperfect democracy but still a
democracy beset with multiple problems
corruption economic inequality crime
it's revealing that in trying to solve
the country's
oblems many ask and say what would
Mandela do or let's not destroy his
legacy amid the sadness in pain
Mandela's death might provide a moment
for South Africans and the world to
reflect on his extraordinary legacy read
his book Long Walk to Freedom Google his
speeches you'll find wisdom and an
exceptional example scroll through your
Twitter timeline today observe your
Facebook feed watch the TV news there's
nothing but love and sadness at his
passing I would not be here today were
it not for the sacrifices he and others
made in toppling apartheid his
principled defiance against oppression
his patience his fortitude forgiveness
commitment to dialogue and engagement I
think are themes that will live on and
in any person trying to make the world a
better place
rest in peace Tata Madiba it was a
privilege being alive for just a small
portion of your long and wonderful life
we will never forget you
it is time for new hands to lift the
burdens
it is in your hands now
you